ready to Rebrand your life and level up
by 2025 in this video I'll show you how
to transform your mindset career and
daily habits into one powerful
integrated system first let's talk about
decision making did you know your brain
makes 35,000 decisions every day the key
isn't just logic or intuition it's
combining both to make choices that
shape your future next I'll reveal the
secret to skill stacking instead of
mastering one skill learn to combine
them imagine being a writer and a coder
that's how you become
Irreplaceable here's the Paradigm Shift
purpose isn't something you find it's
something you build I'll show you how to
align your career with your passions and
create a life that truly excites you and
finally we'll dive into life design your
life is an ecosystem when you improve
one area everything else transforms
curious how to make 2025 your best year
yet watch the full video to unlock the
tools and strategies that will help you
take a Quantum Leap Forward your future
self will thank you